cheerful reaction house minority leader
kevin mccarthy
first let's get your reaction to these
incidents involving the police and the
unrest we see in the country tonight sir
well my heart goes out for all what you
find from the
democrats they don't want to just defund
the police they want to remove
all police officers that's the new cry
but now we're finding what you just
played here
they want to dismantle the supreme court
because they're trying to dissolve
the american way think about it three
coequal branches
they have two branches right now the
only thing that holds them back from
their socialist views going forward
that are unconstitutional like a dc
statehood
is the supreme court that would stand up
for the american people so they want to
pack
the court to protect their power it's
all about one thing
control and do not trust nancy pelosi
when she says she will not move it
remember that's what she said about
impeachment before she moved impeachment
twice
we've watched her time and time again to
come to what the socialist actually
asked for she surrendered to the
socialists
many times before and she will do it
again
so we got the squad now they want to
totally eliminate the police
corps packing d.c puerto rico statehood
and the legislative filibuster
amnesty uh of course now gun control
remember hr1
and then hr one put it all together and
and
now we've got a situation where we have
50 republican senators
and do you have confidence that lisa
murkowski
confidence in ben sasse and mitt romney
that if need be that mitch mcconnell can
say to every republican
we're leaving we're not providing them a
quorum if they're going to abuse this
power
you know the greatest confidence i would
have if we had three more republicans in
the house
we'd be in the majority right now that
would be the greatest check and balance
and remember sean if you study history
hugo chavez didn't have a revolution to
take over venezuela
and make it a socialist nation he won
democracy
then he changed the constitution in the
courts it seems a lot like what the
democrats are doing now
first with h.r 1 they change the
election law to protect their power
they make a federal election commission
that's equally bipartisan republicans
and democrats
and pack it where the democrats have
control they make the taxpayer
pay for the campaign if you get one
dollar from somebody
the taxpayer has to pay you six dollars
that is what we're talking about
total control of what the democrats want
to do and the only thing that can stop
them right now is the constitution
which the supreme court will uphold and
what do they want to do
pack it to protect their power yeah what
they could never get done legislatively
or
at the ballot box all right kevin
mccarthy thanks for being with us